[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: OK, team.
Let's get started for the day.
It's a pleasure to
see all of you guys.
In case you don't
remember, I'm Justin.
I'm the third instructor of 006
that you probably forgot about,
but you're going to see a lot
more of me in the graph theory
part of our course because
that's the part of algorithms
that I like.
If I were reincarnated as a
theoretical computer scientist,
I would probably
go into this area.
Hey, guys.
OK.
We have our PhD admit
visit days coming up
for the next couple of days I'm
working on my camp counselor
cheerleader voice.
So don't make me wake all
of you guys up for the day.
You're not going to like it.
But in any event, so in
6.006 if you look back
at the course outline,
we're officially
starting part two of this class.
There are a few
corollaries to that fact.
So unless there are any
questions about that,
we'll get started with
our new unit in 6.006
which is a graph theory.
If you're wondering, there's
a graph on the screen here.
But of course, we'll fill in
a little bit more information
today throughout our lecture.
When I was learning how to
teach, which I'm still doing,
actually my PhD advisor
told me if you want somebody
to learn something, you have
to write it as big as possible.
And so I'm really leaning
into that approach
today in our slides.
So in any event, so
today we're going
to have our first
lecture on graphs
which I think will somewhat be
a review for many of you guys.
And if it's not,
that's cool too.
Because we'll start
from the beginning
and kind of build
up all the notions
that we need to understand and
process graphs and hopefully
by the end of lecture,
have some style
of algorithm for computing the
shortest path from one vertex
to all the other ones.
So in case we forgot a little
bit of terminology, a graph--
some people call this network,
but sometimes that term is
overloaded with a few
different kind of variations
on the theme--
is a collection of two things.
That's what this
parentheses notation means.
There's a set of vertices
and a set of edges.
And the edges, like you can
see in the sort of third point
on our screen here, are a
subset of v cross v. Now
this is fancy
notation for something
really, really simple.
Because what is this telling me?
This is telling me that an
edge, like in the picture
that we see on the screen here.
it just just something that
connects to vertices together.
So if I think of there being a
pair of vertices, like the from
and the to, then that is a
subset of the cross product
of v and itself.
So hopefully the notation in
that third line on the screen
makes some sense.
This is just fancy notation for
edges are pairs of vertices.
But of course, inside
of that notation
there are two special cases that
we care about in this class.
One is when you have
a directed graph,
and one is when you have
an undirected graph--
because I said them in
opposite order from what's
on the screen.
So in an undirected graph, I
guess we still think of an edge
like a pair of vertices, but
really I should have notated
this slightly
differently-- in fact,
maybe I'll revise it in
the slides before they go
into OCW--
where instead of writing
e equals w comma v,
I should write in
fact equals v comma w.
And notice that there's a slight
difference between the notation
on the slide and what I've
written on the board, which
is the set notation here.
What's the difference between
parentheses and squiggly lines
is that this guy is unordered.
This is a set of things.
And what's on the
board is ordered--
or what's on the screen rather.
And of course, in
an undirected edge
there's no such thing
as an edge from w
to v being distinct from
an edge from v to w.
Those are the same thing.
They're undirected.
It just is a notion
of connectivity.
Whereas in a directed
graph, now we're
going to use that
parenthetical notation
to say that the
edge from w to v is
different than the
edge from v to w.
That's going to make
a big difference.
So for example in the
graph on the right--
let's maybe redraw
it on the board here.
So we have four vertices.
I drew this last night, and
I'm hoping that this example
actually works.
Like that-- can I get from
the upper right vertex
to the lower left vertex
following edges in this graph?
I heard one person.
Everybody on three-- 1, 2, 3.
AUDIENCE: No.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: No, right.
Because if I wanted to--
I mean maybe I think of
drawing this path here--
but of course, if I would
go from the upper right
to the lower left--
this is like the ugliest thing
I've ever done, I'm so sorry--
you can notice that
the edges are pointing
in the up direction here.
So I'd have to go against
the stream of the water,
but that's not allowable
in the directed graph case.
Of course, I'm
already anticipating
the notion of a path which we
haven't really defined yet.
But I think
intuitively, that's sort
of the big difference between a
directed and undirected graph.
Does that distinction makes
sense to all of you all
or have I managed to lose
you in four minutes or less?
Excellent.
So I flipped things a tiny,
tiny bit from the course
notes because I
figured we'd define
what a graph is first
before telling you
what the implications are.
But in any event,
I think it's really
not a big stretch
of the imagination
to say that graphs are
literally everywhere
in our everyday life, right.
Any time that we come up with
a network of stuff connected
together, implicitly the
right abstraction often
in the back of our heads
is to think about a graph.
So some simple
examples that I think
would all come to
mind for us would
be like computer networks--
so the nodes or the vertices of
your graph in that case, maybe
are computers,
and then the edges
are roughly the cables
connecting them together
in my very coarse understanding
of how networks work--
or maybe at a social network--
the nodes are people
on your social network,
and the edges are
friend relationships
or frenemy relationships
or whatever.
In fact, I think you could think
of both directed and undirected
versions of that
particular network.
In road networks, maybe
I'm working for Google
and I want to tell
you the shortest path
between your house and MIT.
Of course, in order to
do that and essentially
behind the scenes, we're
solving some version
of computing the
shortest path between two
vertices in a graph.
That's a tiny bit of
a lie in the sense
that there's a lot of
structure in that problem
that we're not going to
leverage in this course.
A road network is a very
special type of graph,
and if you take an
advanced course maybe
you'll say, well, if I know
a little more about my graph
I can do better than the general
case we'll talk about here.
But the basic algorithms that
we'll talk about in 6.006
are certainly
relevant in that case
and are really the
building blocks
for what goes on
in the tools that
are used every day on your
phone when you open Google Maps
or Ways or whatever.
And of course,
there's many others.
So for instance, an
example that maybe
is a little bit
more subtle would
be the set of states
and transitions
of a discrete thing.
So think about like
a Rubik's cube.
So I could make a
graph where the node
is every configuration
of my Rubik's cube,
like every rotation.
And then the edges
are like can I
get from this
configuration to that one
by making one simple
transition, like one flip.
I don't actually know the
terminology in Rubik's cube,
I have a feeling you
do, for one rotation.
Twist-- thank you.
And of course, there
are many other places.
So for instance, in
my day job here at MIT
I typically teach
computer graphics courses.
And actually graph
theory, although we
talk about it very differently,
appears in that world
constantly.
Because of course, with
sitting behind any 3D model
on your computer is a
giant network of triangles.
This is called a
triangulated surface--
like this torus we see here.
And this is nothing
more than a graph.
And in fact, if you
squint at the algorithms
that we cover in six
eight three eight,
you'll see they're roughly just
graph algorithms in disguise.
In fact, if you take my graduate
course one thing we'll do
is we'll spend a lot of time
doing differential geometry.
And then we'll step
back 10 feet and notice
that exactly the
algorithms we are
using for computing curvature
and bendiness on triangle
meshes, just looks
like a graph algorithm
and can be applied to networks
in exactly the same way.
So it will be a nice
kind of fun reveal there.
And of course, there's one
last kind of fun application.
I actually was gone
the last couple of days
at a conference on
political redistricting.
And the funny thing is
most of the discussion
at that conference was
about graph theory.
And the reason for that is
sort of a theme that shows up
a lot in geometry world,
which is if I take my state,
in this case I think
these are the voting
precincts in some
state or another,
and I look at adjacency
relationships,
then maybe I put a node for
every precinct and an edge
any time that they share a
boundary with one another.
Well now I have a network.
And maybe a region on my graph
is like a connected piece
of this network.
And so anyway, this is one
of these examples where
graphs and networks and
connectivity and so on just
show up literally no
matter where you go.
They're totally unavoidable.
And so that's what we'll be
spending quite a bit of time
on in this class here.
Now you could easily
take, I would argue,
at least three entire courses
on graph theory here at MIT,
and you could easily build a
PhD dissertation doing nothing
more than really simple
problems on graphs.
Of course, in this class
we're limited to just a few
lectures out of many.
So we're going to make
a couple of assumptions
both on the problems we want to
solve, as well as in the graphs
that we care about.
So in particular, one
simplifying assumption,
which actually
really doesn't affect
many of the algorithms
we'll talk about here
but it's worth
noting explicitly,
is that we'll mostly be
thinking about a particular type
of graph which is
a simple graph.
And in fact often, depending
on how you define your graph,
you kind of accidentally
made your graph simple
even if you didn't intend to.
So for example, we
wrote that our edges
were a subset of v cross v.
Which maybe means that I can't
have multiple edges
that sort of traverse
the same pair of vertices.
So let's see an example of
a graph that is not simple.
So sorry, I haven't
actually defined it.
A simple graph is a graph
that has no self loops,
so it can't go from
a vertex to itself,
and every edge is distinct.
So let's make the most non
simple graph we can think of.
Like let's say I
have two vertices.
So maybe if I want to make my--
so there's a graph, right,
two vertices and one edge.
This is simple.
If I wanted to be annoying
and make it not simple,
maybe I take this edge and I'd
duplicate it three times just
for fun.
That violates the
second assumption.
And now to make it even worse,
I could violate the first one
by adding an edge that goes
from this vertex to itself.
This is not simple.
I don't know what you would call
it actually-- general graph,
I guess-- complicated
because it's not simple.
I don't know-- a multigraph.
I always thought of that--
anyway, it doesn't matter.
But in any event,
in this class we're
not going to worry about
this particular circumstance.
And of course, in many
applications of graph theory
that's a totally reasonable
assumption to make.
Any questions about the
definition of a simple graph?
OK, so from now on whenever
we think about a graph,
in the back of our
head we're going
to think of our graph as simple.
There's one nice property
that a simple graph has,
which I've written in really
big text on the screen
here, which is that the
edges are big O of v squared.
And in fact, let's expand
that formula just a tiny bit.
So there's sort
of two cases, one
is when my graph is
undirected, the other
is when my graph is directed.
So if I have a directed graph--
well, let's think about how many
edges we could possibly have.
So an edge is a pair of a
from vertex and a to vertex,
and I can never repeat it twice.
That's sort of like the
second assumption here.
So in particular,
what do we know?
We know that mod E--
or rather the number
of edges in our graph is
upper bounded by what?
Well, I can take any
pair of vertices--
like that-- but I have to
be a little bit careful
because my graph is directed--
so from and to matter here.
So this is v choose
2 is saying that I
can take any unique
pair of vertices,
but I have to put a
factor of 2 in front of it
to account for the fact that
the source and the target
can be flip back and forth.
And of course, if I want
to do the undirected
I don't have to
worry about that.
We'll get E here is less than
or equal to just mod v choose 2.
So this is just a
fancy way of saying
that every edge consists
of two vertices,
and my edges are unique.
And one thing, if
you just write down
the formula for our
binomial coefficient here,
we'll see that both
of these things--
oops, oh, yeah, sorry--
are at worse mod v squared here.
And that makes perfect sense,
because of course, an edge
is a pair of vertices.
You kind of expect there
to be a square there.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: I'm so sorry.
I can't hear you.
AUDIENCE: So the 2
comes from the fact
that it's from the source.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Yes, exactly.
So the 2 for the director
case, comes from the fact
that an edge from v to w is
different than an edge from w
to v. So remember that the
binomial coefficient here, it's
just counting the
number of ways that I
can choose two things
from a set of size v,
but it doesn't care
about ordering.
Yeah, any other questions?
Fabulous.
So why is this going to matter?
Well, these sorts
of bounds, I mean
they might seem a little
bit obvious to you,
but we're going to write
down graph algorithms.
And now when we analyze
the runtime and the space
that they take, we now have
sort of two different numbers
that we can think about--
the number of vertices
and the number of edges.
And so for instance,
if I write down
an algorithm whose runtime
is proportional to the number
of edges, maybe
then genErikally I
could also think
of the algorithm
as having a runtime that looks
like the number of vertices
squared unless I put some
additional assumptions
on my graph.
And so there's some
connection between all
of these different
constants, and it's
useful to kind of keep that
at the back of our head.
That sometimes you'll see a
bunch of different expressions
that really are encoding roughly
the same relationship just
in different language
Of course, that also means
that we can be more precise.
So sometimes a graph is
what we would call sparse.
So in my universe,
almost all graphs
that I deal with in my day to
day life are extremely sparse.
This is a consequence
of topology.
And because of
that, an algorithm
that scales like
the number of edges
might actually be much
preferable to an algorithm
that scales like the
number of vertices
squared because,
in practice, often
there are fewer edges than like
every single possible pair.
And so that's the
sort of reason why
it's we're thinking
about these numbers.
OK, so let's continue making
boring definitions here.
So some other ones that
we should think about
involve the topology or the
connectivity of our graph--
in particular, thinking
about neighbors.
So in general we kind think
about pairs of vertices
as being neighbors
of one another
if there's an edge between them.
We have to be a
little bit careful
because, of course, when
we have a directed edge,
we have to be careful
who's on the sort of giving
and the receiving end of
this neighbor relationship.
Yeah, so let's draw a
really, really simple graph.
So here's vertex 0, here's
vertex 1, here's vertex 2.
And maybe we'll have an edge
going up, an edge going down,
and then a cycle here.
OK.
Now we can define a lot
of different notions
of neighbors-- like the
outgoing neighbor set,
the incoming neighbor set.
And the basic idea
here is that we
want to keep track of edges
going from a vertex and edges
pointing into one.
Yeah, so for instance,
the outgoing neighbor
set, which we're going to
notate as Adj plus here--
what is the outgoing
neighbor set of node 0 here?
Well, if we take a look,
notice that there's
one edge going out of node
0, and it points to node 2.
So of course, this
is a set which
just contains one other node.
And similarly, the incoming
neighbor set of node 0, well
notice that there's one
incoming neighbor from vertex 1,
so that is a set like that.
Now of course, in
an undirected graph
the sort of distinction
between these two things
doesn't matter.
So if you look at our
final bullet point
here, often in the
undirected case
we just drop that plus
or minus superscript
because it sort
of doesn't matter.
In any event, there's one
additional piece of terminology
that matters quite a
bit, which is degree.
And this is nothing
more than just counting
the size of this set.
So the out degree is
the number of edges
that point out of a vertex.
And the in degree is the
number of edges that point in.
So notice in this case,
both of those numbers are 1.
Let's see an example
where they're not.
So in node 1, notice there's
two edges that come out.
So the out degree
of node 1 is 2.
There's one edge that points
in, so the in degree is 1.
OK, so often why are
we going to do this?
Well, we're going to get
a lot of graph algorithms
that like have a FOR loop
over the neighbors of a given
vertex.
And then this degree number
is going to come into play.
It's worth bounding these
things just a tiny bit.
So in particular, one thing
we could think about--
I write too big, and I'm
going to run out of space
really quickly here--
is the following.
So let's take a look at
all of the possible nodes
inside of my graph,
and now let's
sum up all of their degrees.
So I'm going to--
let's see, if I
look at this graph
notice there's three edges
adjacent to this vertex
here, three edges adjacent to
that one, two adjacent to this.
So we sum them all together.
So it's just a convenient
bound to have around--
is to sum these
things, because we're
going to have algorithms that
look like for every vertex,
for every neighbor do something.
So we might as well know
roughly how much time
that's going to take.
Let's think about this.
So what do we know?
In an undirected
graph every edge
is adjacent to two vertices.
So if we think
about how we account
for degree what do we know?
Well we know that
an edge sort of
contributes to the degree
of two different vertices.
So if we think about
it carefully here,
what we're going to see is that
if our graph is undirected--
oh, sorry-- is that right,
wait I'm backward again.
So if I have a graph with
two vertices and one edge
and it is undirected, notice
that is the number of edges
here is 1.
What is the sum of the degree?
Well, it's 1 plus 1 equals 2.
Yeah, so there's a 2 here
if my graph is undirected,
and E if my graph is
directed, if what I'm counting
is just the outgoing degree.
Does that makes sense?
I think I managed to
totally botch that sentence,
so maybe let's try that again.
So if I'm counting just the
number of edges pointing out
of every vertex,
and I count that
over all of the
possible vertices,
then there's two cases--
one is directed and
one is undirected.
So in the undirected
case you get a 2 here
because essentially every
edge is simultaneously
in going and outgoing.
Whereas you get a 1
as the coefficient
in the directed case.
Does that makes sense?
I'm sorry I botched
that for a second.
OK, excellent.
OK, that's going to be a
useful bound for us later on.
Now we think about
graphs, of course,
we just spent the
last couple of weeks
thinking about data structures.
We should think about how to
store a graph on a computer,
and there's many
different options.
In fact, really one thing that
you can do is sort of pair--
just like when we
talked about sets.
There are many different
ways to store sets.
And one way to think
about it was depending
on how we're going to interact
with that set we might choose
one data structure or
another to sort optimize
the types of interactions we're
going to have with that set
and make them as
fast as possible.
This is exactly the
same story for a graph.
So for instance, the world's
dumbest representation
of a graph would be to just
have a long list of edges.
So for example, for
this graph up here maybe
I have 0, 1, that's
an edge, and then 0,
2, that's another edge, and
then 1, 2, and then 2, 1.
There's a big list of edges.
It's really a set.
I don't care about the order.
AUDIENCE: The first one's 1, 2.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: 1--
oh, you're right.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, the edge points up--
thanks Erik, or not Erik--
Jason.
OK, so let's say that I
have a graph algorithm,
and I'm going to
have to do something
like check whether there
exists an edge from v
to w a bunch of times.
How long is that going to
take in this data structure?
Well, if I just have like a hot
mess disorganized list of edges
and I want to know does there
exist an edge from v to w,
all I can do is write a FOR
loop that just goes along this
and says, like this the
edge I'm looking for.
No.
Is that the edge
I'm looking for?
No.
So every single time I
want to find an edge,
it's going to take
me time proportional
to the number of
edges of my graph
which could potentially
be up to v squared.
Yeah, so this is not such
a great representation
of a graph on my computer.
So if we're thinking back
to our data structure
we may say, OK, so an edge list
is probably not the way to go.
Although notice that
the way we notated
what is a graph kind of
looks like an edge list.
But in any event, the
more common thing to do
is to source something
like an adjacency list.
So the basic idea
of an adjacency list
is that what I'm going to store
is a set that maps a vertex
u to everything adjacent to u.
So in other words,
I'm just going
to keep track of all
the outgoing edges
from every vertex.
And now I have to decide, how
am I going to store this object.
And oftentimes,
we're going to have
to answer queries like does
there exist an edge from v
to w.
So how could I do that?
First, I would look
up v, and I get back
sort of a list or a
set of all the things
that are adjacent to v. And
I have to query that thing.
And I want it to be pretty fast.
So maybe what I do
is I store the set
of adjacent stuff as
something like a direct access
array or a hash table to
make that look up fast.
So for example, how
long would it take--
I see, I'm going to
finish the sentence here--
how long would it
take me to check
if an edge existed in my graph?
Well, what would I do?
I would first pull
out this object,
and then I'd look
inside of here.
So if I stored this
as a hash table,
then the expected time I
would have order one look up,
because this is
order one and then
you have another order
one look up there.
So we went from v squared to
one with one simple trick.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does it matter
what direction [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: That's
a great question.
So this is a design
decision here.
I'm sorry, in my head I think
a lot about undirected graphs,
and I'm going to make
this mistake a lot.
And I'm glad that you caught me.
There's a totally
reasonable thing to do,
which is maybe just to keep
track of the outgoing edges
for every vertex.
This is a design decision.
For an algorithm
maybe I want to keep
track of the incoming edges.
Whatever, I just
have to make sure
that it aligns with what I
want to do with my graph later.
Excellent point.
Sorry, as a geometry person
we rarely encounter directed
graphs.
But it's important
to keep remembering
that not everybody works on
the same problems that I do.
OK, now if I wanted to be
totally extreme about it--
as just a third example
of representation,
which actually,
in some sense, you
could think of like
an adjacency list--
we need an adjacency matrix
where now I just keep
a giant v by v array of
like does this exist,
does that edge exist.
Now it's really, really easy
to check if an edge exists.
But now let's say that I
make a graph algorithm that's
going to have a
FOR loop over all
the neighbors of some vertex.
So here, if I wanted to loop
over all the neighbors of u,
I could do that in
time proportional
to the number of neighbors of u.
But if I just have a
big adjacency matrix,
just a bunch of binary values--
like for every pair of vertices
are these vertices
adjacent-- yea or nay.
If I want to iterate
over all my neighbors,
now I have to iterate
over all the vertices
and check is that number
one and then do something.
So actually that can
incur some additional time
and additional space.
Does that makes sense?
So in any event, that's a
sort of a lazy man's graph
representation.
I use it a lot when I'm coding
because adjacency matrices are
easy to work with.
But it does incur a lot
of additional space,
and it's not always the
most efficient thing
even if you have the space
because iterating over
neighbors, it actually can
take quite a bit of time.
OK, so the real point
of our lecture today
is to start introducing sort
of the canonical problem
that we all worry
about on graphs
which is computing paths, in
particular shortest paths.
So the first thing we
should do is, of course,
define what a path
is on a graph.
So we're going to talk about
our graph like a road network.
Let's think of maybe every
node here as an intersection.
So this is a roughly
Kendall Square.
See it's a square.
But in any event, let's
say that I want to find--
maybe a question
one would be does
there exist a way to get
from vertex 1 to vertex 3.
And then a better
question to ask
would be does there exists a
short way to get from vertex 1
to vertex 3.
Then of course, the
first thing I have to do
is to define my enemy.
I have define what I'm
looking for, which is a path.
So a path is nothing more than a
sequence of vertices in a graph
where every pair of adjacent
vertices in that sequence
is an edge.
I think this all aligns
with our intuition
of what a path is in a graph.
So for instance, here's a
path p equals v1, v2, v3.
So notice that there's
an edge from v1 to v2
and also an edge from v2 to v3.
So it satisfies the assumptions
set forth in our definition.
What would not be a
path in our graph--
would be like v1 comma v3,
because there's no edge there.
OK, so if we talk about
paths, then there's
a very natural notion
which is the length.
Length, I guess you could think
of like the number of vertices
in your path minus 1,
or the number of edges
that your path traverses.
Those are the same thing.
So for instance, the length
of the path p here is 2.
Does everybody see that?
A very common coding bug
that I encounter a lot
is adding 1 to that
number by accident.
Because of course, there's
one more vertex in your path
than there are edges.
OK, and there are
many different--
there could be potentially
more than one path
between any pair of vertices.
So let's say that I have
an undirected graph that
looks like the following.
So it's just a square
plus a diagonal.
So here are nodes.
So then a perfectly valid
path from the lower left
to the upper right would be
to go one over and one up,
but of course, there's
a more efficient way
to get from the lower left
to the upper right, which
is to go across the diagonal.
And so when we talk
about the shortest path,
it's nothing more
than the length
of the path that has the
fewest number of edges
or vertices between any pair
of vertices in my graph.
OK, so this is our enemy.
This is what we're after.
It's computing the shortest path
between vertices in a graph.
And this is the thing that
we'll be talking about quite
a bit in this course.
Because of course, it's
a very practical matter.
Like when I want to
solve routing problems,
I want to move packets
out of my network,
I'd prefer not to-- well,
unless I'm doing Tor--
I would prefer them not to hit
too many computers in between.
Then maybe I want a
computer shortest path.
Or on a surface maybe I
want to move information
in a way that's
not too far away.
But of course, there's
sort of many variations
on that theme when we
talk about shortest path
or even just
existence of a path.
So these are three
sort of model problems
that we might solve on a graph.
So the first one,
which in this of course
we're calling the single
pair reachability,
would be the idea that
I take two vertices s
and t on my graph g,
and I ask you does there
exists a path between s and t.
So what would be the
sort of extreme example
where this problem
may not always
give back the answer yes?
Somehow in our head, I
think we think of all graphs
as being connected.
But a perfectly valid graph
the way we've defined it
would be like 10
vertices and no edges.
This function would
be very easy to code
if that were the only
graph you ever cared about.
But any event, the
existence of a path
is already a query
that takes a little bit
of algorithmic thinking.
We haven't figured out
how to do that yet.
Now another problem we can solve
would be the shortest path.
Given a graph and
two vertices, we
might say, well, how far apart
are these vertices of my graph
if I want to use the shortest
possible distance from one
to the other.
Notice that I can use the second
problem to solve the first one.
Because what's the
length of the shortest
path between two vertices that
don't have a path between them?
Infinity or a shrug--
that's actually
a totally valid answer.
Yeah, that's right.
So how could I implement
the reachability code?
Well, I could call my
shortest path code,
and it gives me infinity.
Then I return no,
it's not reachable.
And if it gives me not
infinity, I return yes.
So remember that a key
idea in an algorithms class
is this idea of reduction.
That I can use one
function to solve another.
So in case, if we can
solve shortest path,
then we can certainly solve
the reachability problem
by calling that piece of code.
And then finally we could talk
about single source shortest
path.
So notice now that there's
only one input node here s--
so what this problem
is saying is give me
the length of the
shortest path from s
to every single other
vertex in my graph.
Does that makes sense?
Like maybe I return a big
array with all the information,
every single shortest distance.
So can we solve single
pair shortest path using
single source shortest path?
Absolutely.
I could take s in my single
pair shortest path problem,
compute the shortest path from
s to literally everything else,
and then throw away all of that
information except the shortest
path to t, and now I'm good.
Now I haven't justified that
this is the fastest possible
way to solve that
second problem,
but at least it shows that
if I can solve problem three
I can also solve problem two.
If I can solve from two I
can also solve problem one.
So in today's
lecture, we're just
going to worry
about problem three.
In other words, these
things are sort of
listed in increasing
order of their difficulty.
OK, so in order to think about
the single source shortest path
problem, we're going to make
one additional construction.
And this is an idea called
the shortest path tree.
I got lazy drawing PowerPoint
slides at 2:00 AM yesterday,
and instead thought I'd
draw a picture on the board.
So let's draw a graph.
So here we have a, b--
I'm going to use letters
instead of numbers
to refer to nodes from now
on because I don't want
to confuse the length
of the shortest path
with the index of my node.
So here's a, b, c--
I'm going to match
my notes here--
d, e, f.
Here's a graph--
again undirected
because your instructor likes to
think about undirected graphs.
But I know I'm going
to get feedback that I
shouldn't have done that later.
But in any event,
let's say that I
want to compute the shortest
path from a to everything
else-- or the length rather.
So first of all, even without
talking about an algorithm,
I think it's pretty easy
to guess what it is.
So clearly the shortest path
from a to a has length 0.
The shortest length from a
to b is 1, from a to c is 2--
because I can follow these guys.
Now it gets complicated.
It branched.
So the next shortest path is
length 3, and then 4 like that.
Does everybody agree
with me that the numbers
I've decorated here are
the length of the shortest
path from a to everything else?
But what have I not done?
I haven't told you how to
actually compute the path,
I've just given you
the length of the path.
So I may want a piece
of code that in addition
to doing single source
shortest path length,
also gives me a single
source shortest path.
So initially when I think about
that, I might think about,
well, how do I even write
down a data structure that
can store all of those paths.
Well every path could have
like v vertices in it, right.
It could be that
for whatever reason,
there's a lot of
branching in my graph.
And all the paths
are super long.
Actually, I guess I
have to think about
whether branching would
make them longer or shorter.
But in any event, I could have
a really boring data structure
that just for
every single vertex
keeps track of the shortest
path from a to that vertex.
How big would that
data structure be?
Well, if the only bound I
have on the length of a path
is that--
it certainly at most it takes
all the vertices in my graph--
then any one path
will take v space.
So that would take v
squared space total.
That wouldn't be so good.
Because somehow I have an amount
of information on my graph
currently that's linear.
It's just the
length of the path.
If I want to actually
reconstruct that path,
initially sort of spiritually
feels like I need way
more space to do that.
But the answer is that
we actually don't.
That we're going to
only need linear space,
and the idea for that
is to store an object
called the shortest path tree.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just for [INAUDIBLE]
previous [INAUDIBLE]..
JUSTIN SOLOMON: So the
question was about recursion.
We haven't actually written
down any graph algorithms.
So we're going to defer on
that until we actually recurse.
And then we'll think
about it more carefully.
Yeah, but it's a totally
reasonable question.
There are plenty of recursive
graph algorithms out there.
And then we'll have
to do our counting
very carefully for sure.
Right, so instead, we're going
to define an object called
the shortest path tree.
And the basic trick
here is to say, well,
how did I get from a to c?
Well, there's always a vertex,
which is its predecessor,
on the shortest path.
And shortest path have this
really beautiful property,
which is that the shortest path
from a to c, if I truncate it--
right, so it goes a to b to c--
then the truncated one
is also the shortest path
to that previous vertex.
So let's think about
that a little bit,
because that sentence
was, as usual, poorly
phrased by your instructor.
So let's say that
I have the shortest
path from a to d, which is
very clearly a, b, c, d.
I think we can all agree.
And now I take
like this sublist.
I just look from a to c.
Is there ever a
circumstance when
this is not the shortest path
or a shortest path from a to c?
No, right because if there
existed a shorter path
from a to c, I could
splice it in here
and find the shortest
path from a to d.
Do you see that?
So based on that
reasoning, rather than
string like this giant
set of shortest paths,
sort of actually
applying, in some senses,
recursive suggestion,
instead I can just
think of the one vertex that's
before me in my shortest path.
I'm going to trace backwards.
So let's take a look
at our graph here.
Essentially, the object
I'm going to keep track of
is like a predecessor, right.
So what is the predecessor
of f on the shortest path?
It's actually either d or e.
It doesn't matter in this case.
Maybe the predecessor
is e for fun, right.
What's the predecessor of e?
Well, clearly the previous
vertex on the shortest path
is c.
Similarly for d-- now we
have b and a and a bunch
of arrows that point this way.
So for every vertex
I'm just going
to start an arrow pointing
toward the previous vertex
on the shortest path.
I'm not going to store the
whole shortest path, just
the very last edge.
So first of all, how much
storage does this take?
It takes v space.
Do you see that?
Or the size of the
vertices space.
Because every vertex just
has to store one thing,
which is the previous
vertex on the shortest path.
Now what does my algorithm
for tracing shortest path?
It's really simple.
I just start walking
along these edges
all the way until
I get back to a.
Now this object is called
the shortest path tree.
Notice I snuck in one
additional word which is tree.
Why is that?
Can I ever have a
cycle in this graph?
It wouldn't really
make any sense, right.
These are shortest path.
You should be able to kind
of follow the gradient back
to the original vertex.
OK, so in other words, I'm going
to basically decorate my graph
with one additional thing.
We'll call it p of v which
is the previous vertex
on the shortest path from my
source point to my vertex v.
And what I think I've tried
to argue to you guys today
is that if I have
this information,
that's actually enough to
reconstruct the shortest path.
I just keep taking p of
v, and then p of p of v,
and then p of p of p
of v, and so on, which
sounds more
complicated than it is,
until I trace back to
my original vertex.
And this object conceptually is
called the shortest path tree.
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: If I had an
edge that connected a to d, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh, OK
so the question was,
let's say that our colleague
here added an edge--
this is a great question.
You know somebody was evil,
my adversarial neural network,
stuck an edge here because
it was adversarial,
and it wanted my shortest
path code to fail.
And now somehow the tree that I
gave you is no longer correct.
And my answer to that is yes.
Why is that?
Well, by adding this edge here,
the length of my shortest path
changed.
The shortest path
from a to d is now 1.
So this tree is no longer valid.
I need a new tree.
So now what would be the
previous p of d here?
Well, rather than
being c, it would be a.
Yes, that's absolutely right.
And it actually is reflective
of a really annoying property
of shortest path, which is if
I add one edge to my graph,
the length of the shortest path
to every vertex can change.
Well, I guess with the
exception of the source vertex.
Yeah, and that's actually
a really big headache
in certain applications.
So for instance-- and then
I'll shut up about applications
and do math again--
I work a lot with 3D models.
And there's a big data set of
3D models of like ballerinas.
And ballerinas are really
annoying because sometimes they
put their hands
together like that.
And then suddenly the shortest
path between your fingers
goes from your entire
body to like 0.
And so incremental algorithms
for computing shortest path
can fail here, right.
Because I have to
update like everything
if I accidentally glued
together fingers like that.
So anyway, I'll let
you think about how
you might fix that problem.
If you want to know more,
you should take 6.838.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JUSTIN SOLOMON: If you
change your source node,
the shortest possible
change again.
Yeah, so this is going to be one
of these really boring things
where I'm going
to keep answering
like any time I change
anything about my problem--
I change my source,
I change my edges--
I have to just recompute
all the shortest paths.
There are obviously algorithms
out there that don't do that.
But we're not going to
think about them yet.
OK.
So as usual, I've
talked too much
and left myself about
10 minutes to do
the actual algorithm that's
interesting in the lecture
here--
although actually, it's
really not so complicated,
so I think we'll do OK--
which is how do I actually
compute shortest paths?
Yeah, and the basic
thing we're going to do
is sort of build on
this tree analogy here.
We are going to define one more
object, which I really like--
actually I enjoy this from
Jason's notes because it looks
like calculus,
and I enjoy that--
and that's an idea
of the level set.
And so this is a whole
set of things L sub k.
And these are all the
vertices that are distance k
away from my source.
So for instance, if my
source vertex in this example
is the vertex all
the way on the left,
then L0 obviously contains
just that vertex, right.
L1 is the next one.
L2 is the third one.
But now L3 is a set
of three vertices
because those are all the
things that are distance
3 away from the source.
That's what I've
labeled in pink here.
OK, so that's all that
this notation here means.
Oh, I've made a slight typo
because in this class distance
is delta and not
d, but whatever.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JUSTIN SOLOMON: The
shortest distance--
that's absolutely right.
So for instance, I could
have a very long distance
from L0 to L2, right.
I could just flip back and
forth between L0 and L1,
maybe go over to L4
and then go back.
But that wouldn't be a terribly
helpful thing to compute.
That's absolutely right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Oh,
the red background
is the set L. So for example,
L3 contains these three vertices
because they're all
the things that are
distance 3 away from the left.
I got a little too slick drawing
my diagram late last night.
I'm kind of proud of it.
OK, so essentially if
I wanted to compute
the length of the shortest path
from all the way on the left
to all the other
vertices, one way
to do that would be to compute
all these level sets and then
just sort of check what
level set I'm in, right.
So we're going to introduce
an algorithm called
Breadth-First search
which does roughly that.
So Breadth-First
search, the way we'll
introduce it today is going to
be an algorithm for computing
all of those level sets, L
sub i, and then from that,
we can construct
the length and even
the shape of the shortest path.
And I'm going to move
to my handwritten notes.
OK, and here's what our
algorithm is going to do.
I'm going to write it in
a slightly different way
than what's in the notes and on
the screen, but only slightly.
So first of all, one thing
I think we can all agree on
is that level set 0--
oh, that's-- this
chalk bifurcated--
it contains one node.
What should that node be?
The source because the
only thing that's distance
is 0 away from the source,
is the source node.
OK, and in addition to that,
we can initialize the distance
from the source to itself.
Everybody on three,
what is the distance
from the source to itself--
1, 2, 3.
AUDIENCE: 0.
JUSTIN SOLOMON: Thank you.
See you're waking up
now, it's almost 11:00--
12:00.
What time is it?
Almost 12:00-- OK,
and then finally--
well maybe initially
we don't really
know anything about the array
p, so we just make it empty.
Because p of the source,
it somehow doesn't matter.
Because once I've made
it back to the source,
I'm done computing
shortest path.
So we're going to
write an algorithm that
computes all the level sets and
fills in this array p and fills
in the distances
all in one big shot.
We're going to call it
Breadth-First search.
OK, so let's do that.
So we can use the notation here.
And notice that
there's basically
an induction going on, which is
I'm going to compute level set
1 from level set 0, level
set 2 from level set 1,
and so on, until I fill
in all my level sets.
Does that makes sense?
So here's a slightly different
way to notate the same thing.
I'm going to use a
WHILE loop, which
I know is like slightly
non-kosher, but that's OK.
So I'm going to initialize
a number i to be 1.
This is going to be
like our counter.
I'm going to say WHILE the
previous level set is not
empty, meaning that
potentially there's
a path that goes through
the previous level set
into the next one.
Because as soon as one
of my levels is empty,
notice that like the
Li for even bigger i
are also going to be empty.
There's like never a case when
there's something not distance
i but then distance i plus 5.
OK, so now what
am I going to do?
Well, let's think
back to our graph.
So like now I know that
this guy is distance 0 away.
That's what I started with.
So now I'm going to look at all
the neighbors of this vertex.
And I'm going to make
them distance 1 away.
Does that makes sense?
And similarly here,
this guy is distance 2.
And eventually I'm going to
get in trouble because maybe--
well, what's a
good example here.
I won't even try to draw.
I could run into
trouble if I don't
want to add a vertex twice
to two different level sets.
Once I've put it
in Li then I don't
want to put it in Li
plus 5 because I already
know that it's distance i away.
Does that makes sense?
OK, so what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to iterate over all the
vertices in my previous level
set.
And now I'm going to
look at every vertex that
is adjacent to u.
Because what do I know?
I know that if I can get
to u in i minus 1 steps,
how many steps should it take
me to get to any neighbor of u?
i steps because I can go
through the path, which
is the length of i minus
1, add one additional edge,
and I'll get to that new guy.
So what can I do?
I can iterate over
all of v, which
is in the adjacent set of u.
But I have to be a little
bit careful because what
if I have an edge backwards?
So like for instance,
here I have an edge back
to the source.
I guess this is--
yeah, that's a valid example.
I wouldn't want
to add the source
to the third level
set because I already
added it in the previous guy.
So I want to get rid
of the union of all
of the previous level sets.
Does that make sense?
So in other words,
I'm only going
to look at the adjacent vertices
that I haven't visited yet
in my level set
computational algorithm.
And all I have to do is
update my arrays, right.
So in particular, I'm going
to add vertex v to level set i
because I haven't seen v yet.
I'm going to set the distance
from s to v equal to i
because I'm currently
filling in my level set i.
And then finally what is p of v?
What is the previous
vertex to v in my shortest
path from my source?
It's u, right.
Because that's the guy
in the previous level
set that I'm building
my path from, right.
I'm going to set that to u.
And then-- sorry, I
ran out of space--
but I also have to increment i.
OK, so what does
this algorithm do?
It's just building one
level set at a time.
If we go back to our picture,
so it starts by initializing L0
to just be the source vertex,
then it looks at all the edges
coming out of that--
in that case just one--
it makes that length 1--
and so on.
And so this is
just incrementally
building up all
these level sets.
Now there's a pretty
straightforward proof
by induction that this
algorithm correctly
computes the L's the
p's and the deltas which
is all the information that we
need to compute the shortest
path.
I think you guys can do
that in your recitation
if you still need a little bit
of induction proof practice
here.
And the final thing
that we should check
is what is the runtime
of this algorithm.
I'm going to squeeze it in there
just at the last second here.
So let's take a look.
So first of all, I did something
a little-- oh, no it's OK--
in my algorithm
actually in step zero
I had to make an array which
was the size equal to the number
of vertices.
Remember that in 6.006
how much time does
it take to allocate memory?
Yeah, it takes the amount
of time proportional
to the amount of
memory that I allocate.
So already-- Steph, I see your
hand but we're low on time.
So we're to make it to the end.
Already we've incurred v time
because our shortest pathway
array takes v space.
But in addition to that, we
have this kind of funny FOR loop
where for every node I have
to visit all of its neighbors.
But first of all, do I ever
see a node of twice here?
No, because I'm going
in order of distance.
And the second that I've
seen a node in one level
set, it can't be in another.
That's our basic
construction here.
Well, conveniently for
you guys, you already
proved exactly the
formula that we need.
And if I'm lucky,
I didn't trace it.
Yeah, here we are.
So if we take a look here,
this is exactly the scenario
that we're in.
Because what did we do?
We iterated over all
the nodes in our graph,
and then we iterated over all
the neighbors of those nodes.
And that's the basic
computational time
in our algorithm.
So that FOR loop, or that
WHILE loop rather, in my code
is incurring time proportional
to the number of edges.
So what is the total run time
for Breadth-First search?
Well, we need to
construct that array.
So just at step zero,
we've incurred v time.
And then we have to iterate
over something that takes
up most the number of edges.
So overall our algorithm takes
big O of mod v plus mod e time.
Now, notice that this
is-- you might view this
as kind of redundant.
By the way this--
I have a little bit of
a quibble with Jason.
But in this class we will call
this a linear time algorithm
because it's linear in
the space that you're
using to store your graph.
I think that's a
little fishy personally
because this scale could
scale quadratically in v,
but I digress.
In any event, why do we need
both of these terms here?
Well, notice that if I
had no edges in my graph,
now this term is
going to dominate.
But as I add edges to
my graph, this thing
could go up to v squared.
So this is somehow a more
informative expression
than just saying, well at
worst this is v squared time.
Does that makes sense?
It's a slightly better
formula to have.
OK, so with that we just
squeaked into the finish line.
We have an algorithm for
computing shortest paths.
And I will see you guys
again I guess on Tuesday.